welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss in Black Panther we're kind of
forever is now streaming on Disney plus
and it's absolutely worth the re-watch
as we're learning more and more from the
filmmakers and Marvel's official black
panther what kind of forever podcast and
overlooked details in the screenplay
specifically Ryan coogler's plan to
Center this film on the concept of
rituals and a mysterious concept he
called the ritual of eight this was
something from coogler's mysterious
first draft of black panther 2 in 2020
before Chadwick Bozeman passed away a
concept that he had to let go of as he
reconceived the story around ramonda and
shuri an impressive adjustment that he
and the entire creative team behind this
movie handled quite gracefully but when
you re-watch this movie I submit to you
that thematically shuri's grieving
process follows a similar ritualistic
path in a way that for all of us should
completely recontextualize what's really
going on in the final shot of the movie
in that funeral pyre on the Haitian
Beach is shuri actually seen the spirit
of her brother now if you like at me
looking at movies this way to suss out
their buried emotional Roots I will be
doing this kind of stuff on our new
channel the Deep launching on February
17th with everything everywhere all at
once please subscribe I think you're
gonna love it also Jessica Clements is
working on a full-length re-watch of
wakanda forever to break down dozens of
more details in Easter eggs I cannot
wait to see her analysis when it comes
to the channel next week okay in the
official wakanda forever podcast host
tanahisi Coates interviews the creative
team behind the film and director Ryan
coogler confirmed what many of us
deduced that his original Chadwick
Boseman draft of this film would have
explored t'challa returning from the
blip and how that five-year absence
affected his relationship with his son
Tucson AKA t'challa Jr a lot of the
themes that were in that t'challa
vehicle Drive were still applicable to
what wakanda would be going through if
they launched that guy that first script
we wrote was a father-son story through
and through it was about t'challa and
his kid and it was about a man who was
so affected by his relationship with his
father being a father but the idea was
really about how he culturally lost
because he lost a ton of time with his
kid you know and having to be king in
his championship
right exactly during the living and the
film dealt with tragedies befalling
people into chocolate having to find a
way to cope with these things you know
and the idea of coping with loss and the
idea of ritual was like really heavy in
that script a bit later in this podcast
coogler actually went into a lot more
detail on what he meant by ritual the
first script was based on a ritual you
know like the whole idea that first
screenplay was that t'challa and tushant
were doing something that we call the
ritual of eight the kid turned eight
years old he got to spend eight days
with his father in the bush and during
those eight days he could ask his father
any question that he wanted and his
father had to answer honestly the ritual
of eight Tucson t'challa Jr turns eight
years old he spends eight days with
t'challa in the jungle gets to ask his
father anything he wants and t'challa
must answer truthfully googler said that
he went into child's relationship with
Tucson to open up fresh wounds with his
father to choco when he went on his own
ritual of eight as a boy the idea here
seems to build on a deleted scene from
the 2018 film in which young tanchala
talks to his father t'chaka in the
heart-shaped herb garden after sneaking
around with young Nakia and homes in
this moment tacha gets conflicted
because it's right after he killed his
brother Oakland and so his son t'challa
cheers him up but a great king Bubba
that is why you were always hurry
hurry always but what about when I get
old and gray
and past comes to carry me off to the
ancestors but then I'll be Panther
no beat them back with my panda claws so
coogler has described how he translated
these themes of loss and grief into the
characters of shuri and ramonda and
while there's no ritual of eight in the
film the screenplay reveals there's a
lot more context behind the scenes
between the mother and daughter that we
did see early in the film Ramona takes
shuri on that night hike to this River
clearing you remember the scene you need
to sit here with me
and with yourself it is the only way
you're going to heal from the wound
caused by touchless death I'm fine
mother
you have to worry about me he's gone but
but I'm moving forward t'challa is dead
but that doesn't mean he's gone taking
care of yourself is important so good
thing geology makes it easy to do
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skincare company recognized
in hypebeast birdie mental health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards with
over 6 000 5 Star reviews just take a
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that are dermatologist tested proven to
work and personalized to your needs for
skin care geology's got strengthening
shampoo and conditioner and co-wash
which will transform your routine and
deliver the best hair of your life it
extends the time between washes and
replaces the need for so many products
so you wash your hair less and save
money more they also offer body washes
and deodorants that are free of harsh
ingredients and smell great for skincare
they be covered from all angles you can
fight acne reduce oil-ness prevent
wrinkles combat dark or puffy under eyes
have smoother hydrated skin and Target
signs of aging their daily personalized
skincare routine comes with Too Faced
washes a morning face cream a retinol
night cream and eye cream and right now
for a limited time you can get a five
piece trial set for only 15 if you use
code Rockstar's 70 at checkout it's over
150 a product for just 15 on top of that
you'll get an additional bonus offer on
one of their brand new skin hair and
body products of your choice when you
add it to your trial to get started just
click the link in the description now
the official screenplay of this movie
was released in early January and there
was actually a lot more to this scene
that was edited out if you flip to page
22 we see the scene originally began
with Ramona telling shuri in the River
tribe we have a ritual to honor our
connection to those that have passed on
sure he responds there's a ritual for
everything here somebody has died you
have to do the ritual my neighbor hates
me oh just do the ritual I can't find a
boyfriend don't worry there's ritual for
that but Ramona ignore zern goes on
after your father died I performed this
ritual with t'challa by my side and
Nakia and sure he says ugh don't mention
her name I know she hated being here but
that's no excuse for missing his funeral
Ramona says if rituals are pointless to
you why does it bother you that she
wasn't there that day what is a funeral
if not a ritual and sure he says because
that was my brother's day and for some
stupid reason rituals mattered to him I
don't have time for this mother I need
to go back to my lab and then the scene
resumes as we saw it in the film but
knowing this was in the script gives
what we see Ramon to say next a much
deeper context when that illness took
your brother from us
I had to lead a wounded nation and a
broken world
but I still took time in the bush I
wandered until I found water
set
then I did this ritual that I am about
to show you now I found your brother
in the breeze
pushing me
gently but firm
like his hand on my shoulder took some
time
but he was there
he wasn't their mother
presence that you felt was just a
construct of your mind
brought on so you could feel some
comfort or joy
that's all
what construct does your mind create
when you think of your brother
does it offer you comfort
or torment so now that we know all of
this context some interesting details
emerge From This Moment it's all in the
music and the sound design specifically
we hear a four note curl hum
[Music]
by the end of this film that theme is
revealed to be the opening Melody of
Rihanna's song Lift Me Up
thank you
[Music]
so they may not state it explicitly but
Ramona's ritual with shuri is right in
googler's translation of his ritual of
eight concept Ramona is opening the
floor for sure you to ask her anything
but shuri is rejecting the opportunity
to participate to me this is the film's
most important Scene It sets up why
Charisse sees killmonger not her brother
or Ramona in the ancestral plane throne
room and of course it sets up the final
scene of the film in which Suri is
finally able to complete this ritual in
Haiti burning her White Funeral robes on
a campfire it's a beautiful cathartic
moment in which shuri closes her eyes as
she visualizes moments of her and her
brother from the 2018 film
[Music]
ah the music returns and the closed
captioning on Disney plus includes a
very very important piece of audio
description wind howling softly and we
see shuri she laughs it's one of the
only times in this movie she actually
laughs which has been a whiplash because
every other time we've seen her in the
MCU she's had quite a bit of comic
relief and from here we cut to the
credits on Rihanna's vocals the wind
howling softly was the breeze that
Ramona found to Chala inside of the
gentle but firm hand on her shoulder
shuri is laughing because she sees her
big brother and I don't mean
metaphorically the way we in real life
might sense the presences of our
departed loved ones in the wakanda
mythology of the MCU these are literal
visions and dimensional jumps that these
characters undergo shuriken assume the
heart-shaped herb and metaphysically
transferred to another realm the
ancestral plane when she battled Neymar
at the end of the film as she was
severely wounded from his spear her mind
drifted back to the ancestral plane and
she literally saw her mother ramonda so
I think here on the beach in the smoke
this scientific skeptic who brushed off
her mother's Visions as mental
constructs is now looking through that
smoke to literally see the face of her
brother and that every move shuri makes
from here forward as the gentle but firm
guidance of her brother's hand and I
think that's why in the post-credit
scene shuri loses her [__] went to
chala's son also named t'challa sits
right beside her carrying her brother's
same smile in his same sense of humor
bossed a deity she had written off as
pure Superstition answered her prayers
to bring her brother back to her a kid
who's now encroaching eight years old
ready to partake in his own ritual of
eight hey again keep an eye out for
Jess's thorough re-breaked out of what
kind of forever coming very soon to the
channel and a reminder to subscribe to
the Deep dive you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]